[Musique]
sur les réseaux sociaux beaucoup pensent
que la commune a été fabriqué pour nous
tuer
[Musique]
aujourd'hui dit bonjour julien qu'est-ce
que tu réponds à ceux qui pensent que la
pandémie a été créée par les riches pour
éliminer les pauvres la dépopulation
c'est un vieux fantasme qui a été
réactivé avec l'apparition du sida dans
les années 80 l'idée que les maîtres du
monde voudrait décimé une partie de la
population de la planète mais ça ne
répond à aucune logique si les riches
sont riches c'est parce qu'il ya des
gens pour créer des richesses et si
c'est vrai ils s'y prennent mal parce
que entre 1950 et les années 2010 on est
passé de 2 milliards et demi d'habitants
sur la planète à 7 milliards et demi et
on prévoit 11 milliards d'ici 2100 il ya
quelques années billets ça fait une
conférence où il prévoyait qu'une
pandémie allait s'abattre sur le monde
et là quelques mois voir la crise
alimentaire il participe à une
simulation de pandémie c'est quand même
étrange non non en l'occurrence cette
simulation n'avait rien à voir avec kobe
19 quant aux différentes occasions il
s'est exprimé pour alerter sur un risque
de pandémie ça relève de la prospective
tout simplement on devrait le considérer
bill gates comme un lanceur d alerte
plutôt que de le suspecter d'un complot
criminel mais il n'a pas dit qu'il
fallait diminuer la population mondiale
n'ont plus ce qu'il a dit c'est que la
vaccination pouvaient contribuer non pas
à réduire la population mais à ralentir
la croissance démographique en réduisant
la mortalité infantile ça ne veut pas
dire qu'on va supprimer des gens avec
les vaccins c'est même le contraire le
fait de savoir que leurs enfants plus de
chance de vivre conduira les parents des
pays pauvres à concevoir moins d'enfants
très bien mais qu'est ce qui nous dit
que la coved n'est pas un virus conçu
dans un laboratoire militaire d'abord on
a pas le moindre début de commencement
de preuve de ça ensuite la thèse selon
laquelle ce virus serait une arme
biologique créé intentionnellement puis
échappé d'un laboratoire ne tient pas
pourquoi parce qu'une arme biologique
l'idée c'est de pouvoir l'utiliser sur
une population et demi en l'assimilant
donc il faut que ce soit à la fois
meurtrier sélectif en le kobe 19 c'est
le contraire on a affaire à un virus
certes dangereux mais finalement peu
létale est pas du tout sélectif
puisqu'il s'est répandu sur l'ensemble
du globe mais alors comment ça se fait
si on prend le cas des etats-unis que ce
sont les noirs qui ont été les plus
touchées j'ai lu que le coronavirus tué
quatre fois plus les noirs que les
blancs c'est vrai aux etats unis le coc
vide que plus les noirs parce que les
noirs américains sont sur représentés
dans les populations défavorisées on
sait qu'elles ont moins accès aux soins
que leur niveau de santé relatif est
inférieur à celui des populations plus
aisés quelles sont donc plus touchés que
la moyenne par le virus et puis il ya un
autre point les personnes les plus
défavorisées sont aussi les premières
victimes de la désinformation en matière
de santé elles vont donc en plus avoir
tendance à différer la prise de
traitement où la vaccination donc en
gros ceux qui en ont le plus besoin sont
ceux qui se font le moins vacciner c'est
exactement ça il ya une corrélation très
nette entre les zones qui concentrent
les populations difficulté est celle où
le taux de vaccination est plus faible
on y trouve des gens à la fois
vulnérable sur le plan immunitaire avec
des comorbidités plus nombreuses et en
plus une défiance plus fortes à l'égard
des vaccins il ya quand même cette idée
que pour résoudre les problèmes il
faudrait une sorte de saignée
démographique dans ce cas pourquoi on
taxe les cigarettes et pourquoi on fait
des campagnes de prévention contre
l'alcool ou contre l'obésité s'il y
avait au dessus de nous une puissance
qui voulait vraiment nous assassiner
mais il suffirait de blessés nous
empoisonner
[Musique]